le système barrière un dispositif de
surveillance des frontières ou de sites
stratégiques principal produits exportés
par la société saint-quentinoise à terme
aces 70% du chiffre d'affaires de cette
pme est réalisé sur les exportations
avec comme principal client la chine à
l'issue de la réalisation du
démonstrateur franco-chinois barrière
nous avons aujourd'hui des perspectives
des jeunes de 300 systèmes 300 système
il faut savoir que la part d'internet se
situe entre 800 mille et un million
d'euros
donc vous voyez sur dix ans 300 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les prises de commandes pour 2010 9 à
l'export devrait atteindre les 97
millions d'euros burkina faso arabie
saoudite thaïlande la stratégie de
l'entreprise s'appuie aussi sur une
présence locale directement dans les
pays après la vente
ensuite et de créer des filiales ces
mêmes filiales peuvent servir de
plateforme commerciale et d'assurer le
service après vente dans cinq ou six
pays
mais en même temps de prospecter et
d'élargir les possibilités de croissance
de la terre-mère trois zones
géographiques sont ciblés par à terme s
l'asie le moyen-orient et l'afrique
avec une présence dans 40 pays africains
l'afrique a un gros potentiel dans le
domaine de la sécurité
malheureusement du fait de la situation
sécuritaire du pays et principalement
les pays du sahel
cette année l'entreprise prévoit une
croissance de 30% avec un peu plus de 40
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
objectif dans les prochaines années
dépasser les 50 millions d'euros